this is Michael Hayden who was formerly
director of the CIA and the NSA so
please join me in welcoming Michael
Hayden to the stage thank you good
afternoon
thanks for the opportunity to come and
offer my perspective about the future of
truth because my narrow lane is
essentially the secret pursuit of secret
truth all right but it plays to the to
the larger to the larger Enterprise in
fact and I think because a bit of my
background I'm very concerned about the
future of the of the larger question of
truth so let me talk a little bit about
what it is we do in intelligence when I
go into the Oval Office and and by the
way what I say is applicable at all
levels of intelligence but we'll start
with the oval because it's my most
recent experience the intelligence
briefer in the dialogue with the
president fundamentally has the task of
setting the left and the right hand
boundary of logical legitimate policy
discussion which is different than
saying the intelligence is solely
determinative of the best course of
action left right hand boundary but
other legitimate underscore legitimate
factors values politics policy resources
timing all come in to that equation but
you set the left and the right hand
boundaries now the boundaries we set are
a bit reflective of the kind of language
you've heard earlier from this stage in
terms of objective reality truth
I actually am fond of saying that my
profession is as much a child of the
Enlightenment as any of the other
professions you're going to hear
discussed up here it's evidence-based we
base it on fact we seek for data we try
to draw generalized conclusions on a
good day we have humility in the face of
complex
just like you're supposed to do so we
create these left and right hand
boundaries now what's been really
fascinating to me back home is that the
high friction points of the Trump
administration have been with
intelligence science scholarship
journalism and what I will call the
judiciary and law enforcement and what
do those five have in common they are
all in their own way evidence based
institutions now truth and lending here
I said intelligence is the thumb here
right for most of my professional life
we have not been quite grouped that way
with those other institutions
intelligence has kind of been out here
largely about how we acquire information
which could be the subject of a later
Nobel weekend all right and great debate
but that has been muted in my personal
experience we have been what we the
espionage guys have been welcomed into
the fact-based Club with open arms
because we are indeed fact-based and
we've been equally abused by the current
administration intelligence in quotes
fake news so-called judges nutjob
director of the FBI and so on
right so we do have this this
commonality with other evidence based
institutions even though very frequently
that's not as obvious as it should be
let me describe for you a little bit of
the dynamic of briefing a President of
the United States and this is a bit of a
level setting I mean we're looking upon
this administration as a peculiarity and
there are peculiarities okay but there
are some commonalities as well so let me
let me explain it to you the way I
explain it to my countrymen back home
the Intel guy and the policy maker their
director of CIA and the president have
to get into the same room and in this
case it's a room in downtown Washington
without any corners all right it's it's
the Oval Office but the Intel door is
labeled facts
the president's door the policymakers
door is labeled vision right you know
the one you voted for so that's not
illegitimate fact vision world as it is
that's where we should be anchored world
as we want it to be he wants to take it
to another place fact vision as is want
to be inherently inductive we swim in a
sea of data and try to draw generalized
conclusions inherently deductive taking
the first principles again the ones you
voted for and apply to a specific
circumstance fact vision as is inductive
deductive inherently pessimistic it just
comes with the job Bob gates who is DCI
before he was Secretary of Defense
fondly says when a CIA analyst stops to
smell the flowers she looks around for
the hearse inherently optimistic
otherwise they would not have
interviewed with you for the job fact
vision as is want to be inductive
deductive optimistic pessimistic
permanent condition the and so there's
always this step function this tension
that we have to deal with when we've got
a new president I suspect it was the
easiest in the history of this
relationship when George Herbert Walker
Bush was elected president the United
States because as many of you know he
used to come into the room through the
other door he used to be the DCI I
suspect it would not have been much of a
heavy lift
if Secretary Clinton had been elected
president I mean she had gotten this
treatment for four years as Secretary of
State I I fantasized that the first PDB
president's daily briefing for Secretary
Clinton would begun was something along
the lines of her looking at the briefers
and saying so where were we
and just picking it up there is no doubt
there is no doubt that the creator
has seen fit in President Trump to give
him more than three or four additional
doses of all these characteristics that
I described over here this was always
going to be higher harder than average
in terms of the fact-based guys getting
into the head of the vision based
occupant of the Oval Office because of
just the personal traits of Donald Trump
inherently instinctive intuitive almost
preternaturally confident in his own
abilities in his own judgment when you
look at the kinds of judgments he makes
it is very clear to me that he puts
greater stock into who is telling him
something and the relationship he may
have with that person then what is being
told him or the evidentiary train that
supports what is being told him so we
always knew if we're going to go brief
Donald Trump and it's going to be hard
it is a great American tragedy that the
first time we had to go climb that
mountain to get over that hump to begin
to break through this particular
personality that the creator had made it
is a great American tragedy we had to do
it over an issue that a lot of other
Americans not the intelligence briefers
but a lot of other Americans were using
to D legitimize his election to the
presidency of the United States I can
think of no more perfect storm in terms
of the perennial task of my guys getting
into the head of the person that the
nation has decided to impart a great
deal of sovereignty on Michael Gerson
Michael Gerson is a writer for The
Washington Post Michael used to be
george w bush's best speech writer that
second inaugural
the soaring language of that that's
that's Michael Michael Gerson Michael
says
that Donald Trump lives in the eternal
now think that he lives in the eternal
now for him there is no history for him
there is no future or more accurately
for him he is fairly indifferent about
consequence the eternal now
you heard Maggie intensely transactional
no past no future now a lot of people
think the job of intelligence is to go
in there and predict the future that is
not true
all right what's yogi Berra's line
predicting is hard particularly about
the future okay so we rarely try to do
that now it's you know bolt of lightning
when we have the moment and when we say
we know this is going to happen and that
informs a policymaker that's good but by
and large our task is to give this man
context our job is to give this man
historical context cultural context
economic context did I tell you that the
president lives in the eternal Nile and
do you see the challenge that that then
creates I think we saw the worst
manifestation of that with that horrific
Muslim and executive order that was
shoved out the door on day two of the
administration now it's not that the
president got a briefing on that before
he decided to push it out the door that
was coming out the door no matter what
but it was coming out the door
absolutely fact-free based upon that
intuitive preternaturally self-confident
I know how this works
view of the world that was reflected in
campaign language that said we have an
existential threat being presented to us
by refugees and we have an absolutely
dystopian vetting system and in terms of
who it is we let inside this country
both of those are absolutely wrong in
fact and my government made a decision
that not only was not needed it
a decision that actually made us less
safe because by doing that act we
embraced the narrative of the worst
parts of Islam the part that wants to
say there is undying enmity between
Islam and the Western world that's what
happens when the Intel guys don't have a
chance to get in there and create the
left and the right hand boundaries of
logical policy discussion thank you all
very much for your attention
[Applause]